Moviegoers can trust the "Transformers" franchise
to deliver plenty of carnage on a
blockbuster scale, but the films
aren't exactly critical darlings. Will
"Rise of the Beasts" change all that?
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" features
a star-studded voice cast that includes the
Academy Award-winning Michelle Yeoh. The story
sees the titular shape-shifting robots team up
with the Maximals for a pulse-pounding adventure.
But will the latest sequel fare better than
previous flicks, or will it be dismissed
as just another loud, messy action movie?
The good news is that "Rise of the Beasts"
isn't the worst installment of the series,
according to Rotten Tomatoes.
As of the making of this video,
the Steven Caple Jr.-directed actioner
is somewhere in the mid 60s to low 70s
depending on when you see this, making it one of
the most well-received franchise outings to date.
Owen Gleiberman of Variety praised the movie for
being more grounded than previous
"Transformers" flicks, writing,
"It's got a relatable human story that works, and
thanks to a script that actually has sustained
bursts of dialogue, the robots felt more real
to me as characters than they usually do."
"This is probably a lot for you, huh?"
At the same time, this is still a "Transformers"
movie, which means some reviews are guaranteed
to be negative. The latest installment has
already garnered its fair share of detractors,
but the Rotten Tomatoes rating suggests that the
fans currently outweigh the naysayers. With that
in mind, let's examine what the critics
are saying about "Rise of the Beasts."
The positive reviews of "Rise of the Beasts"
share the consensus that it's a fun time at
the movies. Furthermore, unlike previous
films about the Autobots and Decepticons,
the franchise's seventh installment has plenty of
heart to complement the machine-driven carnage.
Frank Scheck of the Hollywood Reporter
believes that "Rise of the Beasts" will
entertain long-term fans, especially those
who grew up playing with the toys that paved
the way for the movies, cartoons, video
games, and other media. Scheck wrote,
"These Hasbro action figures,
and their onscreen incarnations,
are capable of reducing even the
most mature, jaded adult into an
awestruck child who just wants to get
down on the floor and play with them."
Elsewhere, ComicBook.com reviewer Liam Crowley was
impressed with the action set pieces and
the film's entertainment value, writing,
"The action is pulse-pounding. The
summer movie season has been in full
throttle for just over a month, and 'Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts' sends that popcorn
blockbuster momentum into full gear."
Steven Caple Jr.'s direction also received
some positive feedback from critics,
with Uproxx noting that he shows a genuine
affection for the characters that goes a
long way. The reviewer also gave the movie props
for including some memorable '90s needle drops,
so viewers can expect a banging soundtrack.
While the positive reviews tease a heartfelt
action-adventure movie, some of the naysayers
believe that "Rise of the Beasts" is unremarkable.
For example, Valerie Complex of Deadline
praised the action sequences while arguing
that the story is nothing to write home about:
"'Rise of the Beasts' is another generic
story about an intergalactic menace from
the sky that carries all the plot
predictability of a broken clock."
Indiewire reviewer Christian Zilker
offered a more scathing evaluation
of the film, stating that it's
just another soulless blockbuster,
which is a bad look now that movies based
on toy brands are evolving. Zilker wrote,
"It's as if some executive saw Mattel and Greta
Gerwig turning 'Barbie' into genuine art, so they
made a George Costanza-style decision to veer
in the opposite direction purely out of spite."
Charles Bramesco of the Guardian echoed these
sentiments and highlighted some issues with the
film's script, writing that the film might confuse
viewers who aren't familiar with the series:
"Everything has a vague partial
finish, as if director Steve
Caple Jr and the five-person brain trust
responsible for the script banked on the
audience's familiarity with the shape of
a movie to fill in the gaps they've left."
Curious if "Rise of the Beasts" rises
above the franchise's less-than-stellar
reputation? The latest "Transformers"
installment hits theaters on June 9th.